starting from the instant we form an
awareness of the world all the way up
until the final second before we die we
will without doubt experience many
moments in which life goes very wrong
moments where a friend betrays us
moments where we make a big mistake
or fail at something we worked really
hard at moments where someone we loved
decides they no longer feel the same for
us or we no longer feel the same for
them moments where we lose someone close
far too early and everything else in
between from small to big annoying to
tragic there will continue to be moments
where our self the world and humanity
appear to all be in complete conflict in
disarray at a very young age
perhaps rightfully so life seems to be
mostly candy playgrounds fun and cartoon
mice the universe feels like it is made
for us throughout childhood things in
popular culture like movies TV shows and
advertising reinforce this hopeful
optimism by selling us ideals of a life
filled with easy friendships love at
first sight exciting lifestyles
successful fulfilling careers and cool
products that will all culminate into a
perfect smooth life of course as we grow
further past our youthful innocence the
world increasingly reveals itself to be
far more complicated and convoluted as
we experience more of life our youthful
optimism is beaten further and further
into submission as we are continually
disappointed by its inability to align
with the real conditions of the world at
this point the individual is often
compelled to surrender any form of naive
optimism and replace it with some degree
of pessimism arguably any honestly
examined life goes through this
transition at first this might sound
rather somber and bleak and if left here
it very well can be however with the
proper consideration perhaps there is a
way in which we can leverage this
pessimism and use it to our advantage
perhaps there is a way through pessimism
and out the other side into an adapted
and more reasonable optimism not the
sort of delusional optimism that is
ignorant to the sombre truths of our
condition and the bad things that will
inevitably happen but rather an optimism
that exists in spite of it all arguably
all great philosophies and religions
incorporate some varying degree of
pessimism in their
Foundation what reason would
philosophies and religions have to exist
if it weren't first for their admissions
of the pains confusions and
uncertainties of life the philosophy of
stoicism suggests that the universe is
indifferent to what we want from it
Buddhism says that life is fundamentally
suffering existentialism and absurdism
say that we are stricken by our need for
meaning in a life that is meaningless
Christianity proclaims that the
condition of humankind is inflicted with
temptation and imperfection along with
many others these schools of thought
realized that life contains fundamental
pessimism x' however what is powerful
important and lasting about any good
philosophy or frame of thinking is what
it attempts to do with these pessimism
x' a helpful philosophy first realizes
and admits the sad troublesome and often
tragic conditions of our life and then
attempts to grapple with them in order
to find some way of overcoming and
living in spite of them a healthy
serving of pessimism is necessary in our
ability to adequately deal with this
life it helps us mitigate our
expectations and serves as padding
against life's constant attempt to beat
our spirit out of us pessimism
counterbalances the ridiculously
optimistic expectations of the culture
we live in and helps us adapt out of the
deeply detached unrealistic perspective
that we likely formed as a young child
it reminds us that things won't always
go our way or always be that nice but
rather things will go wrong a lot and
that despite this we could still be ok
paradoxically we must recognize that
through a certain quality of pessimism
we can better assist a more reasonable
optimistic experience of life
we are all struggling and improvising
our way through this strange existence
constantly confused and unsure no one is
perfect or normal in any traditional
sense we all make mistakes big and small
no one knows who or why they are
happiness is hard and unclear there is
greed tragedy malevolence in this world
that we have and will continue to
experience and at any moment this whole
world and all of humanity could end for
any number of reasons yet despite
everything that was just said prior the
thought of it all ending should and does
make us sad and tremble with fear we
don't want it to end in spite of the
chaos uncertainties and hardships we
want to go on we want to endure we want
to see what we can do
overcome an experience in the face of it
all in this we find the hopeful spirit
and strength of humankind we find the
optimism in the pessimism this game of
life appears to have rules some that we
can understand and tamper with most of
which we cannot some that work in our
favor plenty that do not where these
rules come from and why they are the way
they are is completely and utterly
unclear what is clear however is that at
this moment they are and because they
are we are to be completely optimistic
about the rules always working in our
favor would be foolish however to be
completely pessimistic about the game as
a whole simply because the rules don't
always work in our favor would be
equally foolish what game is a game at
all where the rules always work out in
the players favor what interests would
this be what experience would there be
to have to give up on life entirely
would be like throwing out a game
because we lose sometimes as if the game
would be worth playing if we knew we
would win every play there is courage in
facing the realities of pessimism and
there is strength to be formed in its
name we must be pessimistic about life's
conditions in order to face their
realities but we must also be optimistic
about our abilities to face their
realities and form strengths meaning and
experience through them like dirt is to
flowers like darkness is to light and
like silence is the song pessimism is to
optimism there is potency beauty and
wonder in this life to be made
experienced and shared on behalf of
life's conditions as they stand and
perhaps only in the conditions as they
and including all the undesirable and
unfortunate can any of it be at all
rather than being optimistic about the
possibility of finding things and ideas
that will rid ourselves in our lives of
disorder defectiveness confusion and
vulnerability perhaps we should attempt
to be optimistic about the potential
value found in accepting and enduring
these things in the classic analogy of a
glass of water filled to its midpoint
the debate has always been whether the
glass is half-full or half-empty
of course however it is both at the same
time if something has half of two things
it is in fact half of both the emptiness
and fullness comprised the whole of the
proverbial glass when we realize this we
see that the glass could at any point be
knocked over and shattered into a bunch
of little pieces never to be again but
we also see that as of right now it
hasn't been
[Music]
you